c'est vrai que nous sommes dans une
situation atypique en France France et
Chypre sont les seuls à ne pas autoriser
les casinos
nous avons et nous avons lancé une étude
qui est une étude c'est la première
étude qui est vraiment sérieuse et
indépendante des acteurs économiques sur
l'offre illégale en France
nous avons sollicité KPMG nous aurons
les résultats de cette étude permettant
de savoir exactement ce que représente
vraiment l'offre illégale en France et
vous savez que l'offre illégale en
France elle est largement composée de
l'offre de casino
à ce stade ce que je peux dire c'est que
l'offre de casino est une casino online
c'est une offre dont les caractères
addictifs sont documentés donc la
régulation si elle devait autoriser
cette offre devrait nécessairement
prévoir des garanties supérieures sur
la protection du joueur et que par
ailleurs nous avons en France une
situation qui est atypique par rapport
aux autres pays puisque nous avons un
réseau de casino qui irriguent entre
guillemets le territoire et d'après les
premiers calculs que nous avons fait si
une offre de casino online devait être
autorisé en France
ça conduirait probablement à une perte
de 30% des casinos physiques
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
toute une série de paramètres
économique juridique
état du soin qui doivent être prises en
compte avant de prendre une décision de
cette ampleur